i want you to get your pee pee touch so
we're just helping yeah i do okay i mean
i would like if i had a younger sister i
would let you date her for sure yeah
because i don't think you're gonna touch
her
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to big mood we
have all the ladies here we have nikki
we have gina
jess is here
and tiff gina's wearing my clothes and
it looks like i'm wearing gina's clothes
it looks like you guys swans
i'm gina
and i've got a really strong side bang
yeah
i just got done making candle crystal
cats things
i just got done you know it's funny it
actually looks like you would own that
gina like i didn't even think that that
was nicki's
but
all right anyway well today we're gonna
be doing another dating profile review
because you guys loved the first one so
much you requested us to do another one
and these profiles that we have here
today they were submitted to us after
that first episode oh and i'm actually
here this time yeah gina wasn't the last
one gina was in here so now i really
want to get her perspective i get to
judge these people gina loves judging
people let's go
who's the first one all right so the
first one that we have here so okay in
the last episode we
we didn't really have a lot of straight
men i don't right yeah we didn't we had
one we had one one we speculated
but we figured he was the straight one
yeah out of all the ones we looked at
last time it was a couple girls couple
yeah a couple games and then one
straight guy okay guys and then now so
we actually have a straight dude here
today he writes hey bg girls big mood
girls i just want to submit my hinge
dating profile for critique smiley face
so we're going to keep them anonymous
yes we're going to give them some names
i think gina's actually a pretty good
name or something yeah what's his name
give them some names uh this is um
jefferson
jefferson jefferson person okay all the
other ones were like screen dating
oh did you guys want like
they're all dead presidents okay
okay so the first photo we have here oh
jefferson jefferson
he looks like a nice guy yeah wait
that's an o because i thought that was
kind of nice like you're showing off
it's like it is but i i still see it as
a he looks like a kid with a bike he's a
backpack i could see that looks like he
just got home from school yeah we don't
know he might be really young so just
for the audience
i didn't say it was bad he's standing in
front of a bicycle and like uh nikki
said with a backpack there's like a bag
in his hand wait are we gonna show a
picture of a blur face yeah oh we just
put a black bar over there
yeah all right so you're thinking he's
really little little boy here no no i
didn't say you're pretty much
no i'm just saying this picture strikes
me as a nice guy yeah because he has
this child-like innocence of he's in
like gym shorts and a t-shirt with a
backpack and a bicycle it looks like he
just got done with school and maybe he's
going to college so maybe it's not a bad
thing maybe he's getting his master's i
don't [ __ ] know
jefferson this picture makes me want to
like um
oh he seems cool like yeah this guy's
like a brother to me but you know i'm
not going to be not yet exactly a nice
guy yeah yeah
he's got a really sweet smile he does is
this his profile picture like is the the
main one i've never used i don't know i
don't think this is the top one because
the top one usually has all the stats
underneath it okay so i think he may
have screenshotted them out of that okay
because i've said this before but
personally i like a closer up shot as
the first yeah closer up for sure i
agree this is too far away to be the
first one i'm not sure if it is but i
don't i don't think it is okay just in
case yeah that would be a critique so
the reason why i was like oh it's not a
bad thing because then the way i
received it because we all have
different perspectives different no i
the way i received wait what did you say
the way i received dicks no no she
no um no the way i received your guys's
arm was was like in a negative tone so
that's why i was like oh not negative
just nice guy which is i understand
sure yeah yeah he told reference to what
you guys are saying because my initial
first reaction was
like oh he's he's showing a an activity
that he likes to do it didn't come off a
little boy to me
it just came off like oh he's showing
like some of his interests he likes to
ride bikes okay i can get that i would
say if your interest was bike riding
like i would expect bike gear that's a
good point like you're a biker
you're not like the super geared up kind
of bike yeah like nikki was saying so
he's gonna pick you up on his handlebars
yeah so that's what i'm questioning like
but also this is the first picture we're
seeing first so like the first picture
usually sets the tone for you but maybe
if we look at some others we can yeah
and that's why if this was like a second
or third picture okay yeah but like if
it's your first picture i would change
that just say i don't know if it is but
if it is also the the shorts are so
baggier of someone from my high school
like in my era like 2000 2007. so this
whole entire look here is like he's
second see from his face he's actually
really handsome with a really cute smile
if he grew out his hair and had a more
like grown-up haircut not that short
spiky hair from middle school cut he can
be really handsome if he and if he got
more fitted clothes his outfit was too
bad
more adult because this is i just got
out of school after basketball practice
before yeah in 2004 yeah
it's too baggy
uh says together the prompt is together
we could and then his response is go on
a date and bond over chicken nuggets all
right this is so childish
see
that's like the how old is he the
caption place
the poses is reading very young teenager
not sexually experienced yet yeah he
looks like he probably doesn't [ __ ] he's
looking for a friend he looks like a
heap of a lover he looks like he he's
like the
the the duckling before the the glow up
yeah so right now i'm getting i play the
clarinet and i love solving rubik's cube
yeah we're looking at his childhood
album here yeah i'm i i would think that
this profile would be great for like a
babysitter's app yes like i would hire
him to babysit my niece and nephew
yeah
like he looks really sweet and
trustworthy like a tutor
yeah tutor math tutor for sure but he's
not ugly or nerdy
it's just the way he's dressing like
and when you're presenting yourself on a
dating profile like
i just would i needed a little bit more
of a romantic touch or like a more of a
sex appeal yeah
that's true okay next one
this is the one with the stats okay so
that means 21. okay
yeah he went to rutgers okay he's
christian his religion is christian he's
a liberal yeah from new jersey
straight works in a daycare i mean he
looks like he'd be good with kids yeah
he does it
yeah so the previous photo we didn't
describe it but he was sitting on a
fence and that seems to be his
first photo of his dating graphics
sweater yeah shorts again lots of
carriers lots of colors he wears very
colorful 21 is young but he's also old
enough to dress more as an adult not
like i'm still wearing my high school
stuff yeah true yeah
what year was he born if you saw oh my
god
2020.
when i realized that i was oh my god
he's my brother's age born in 2000
that's crazy people are people were born
in 2000 damn and they're like actual
adults at bars yeah thinking it's weird
later now oh that's so weird super weird
uh this one oh so then he ends up like
extending the top part where it says
that he drinks sometimes he doesn't
smoke he doesn't smoke weed
no drugs yeah no drugs i wouldn't guess
that from his picture he's a cute so see
the next photo here it says me in the
wild and then it's it's a close-up photo
of him with a cute little smile and then
there's like greenery in the background
that would be better for the opening one
because i could actually see his face
like we need the first one needs to i
need to see that face so move that one
up to the front and he's got a good
smile too so yeah jeffy
oh my god jefferson i'm telling you
right now just get that long hair with
you yes yes
it's gonna do you so he's got that like
basketball hair yeah that's what's
making him look super young
if he had a different hairstyle like
that particular hairstyle i could
picture it on him and the outfit
get an undercut let your hair grow out a
little bit get an undercut sweep it up
to the side and maybe get casey's
haircut yeah
my husband's haircut yeah
put a picture of casey on the screen
casey
yeah because there's a picture up on
your beautiful face this haircut looks
like um my mom still takes me to the
barber i've gone through the kids
it's the same barber he's had since he
was a kid he could totally glow up
though
he's got great teeth great skin nice
eyes you've seen everything a bit of an
adult makeover yeah yeah
yeah
i would hit on facial hair even growing
in i'm like i would love to see what
that really looks like okay but he's
asian so facial hair
what i really like about a man is strong
hair follicles i mean can't you tell
like my husband yes strong hair
okay what else do we got no more graphic
tees and oversized shirts yeah yeah okay
photo here is the prompt is the one
thing i'd love to know about you is and
he wrote what kind of hobbies and
interests drive your life
okay okay it's pretty generic oh then i
read the caption on the next picture and
it's already reading us so youngstown oh
no yes is it a picture with his mom it
says so the next picture it's that he
captioned it as seen on my mind oh it's
his siblings
probably like family members it looks
like little kids like he's hugging
they're really happy
i mean it just still feels like you live
with your mom mm-hmm he might which is
yeah but like as a child like uh it's
still exuding this like
well if he's 21 he's probably dating
like
18 year olds
21 is that like cusp where you want to
go out with like you want to go to bars
or places where you can drink with
people
so you might be i mean a lot of guys
still dating a couple years that's true
a lot of people a lot of guys they down
so i don't know maybe 18 year olds like
see this through a different lens okay
maybe maybe my old eyes yeah we're just
so pictured
you're too much of a child we can't [ __ ]
a child i was thinking about when i
started drinking up bars when i was 21
he was seven
oh my god
yeah yeah i feel like i could be his mom
yeah you know so you gotta remember
we're all thirty sorry
yeah we're
[Music]
i'm the closest to 30 out of all of us
yeah you are chef
okay next photo so it's the prompt says
i want someone who he wrote i can make
stupid jokes with and bond over marvel
18
a
star wars pokemon oh he's a nerd yeah
anime and other nerds i love nerds i
love nerds but i like secret nerds like
where i find out you're a nerd oh my god
yeah yeah what do you think about this i
mean he's just kind of probably dated a
really super nice girl right like
he's not he's not capturing like the
baddie with this what really he wants
about it yeah yeah so i mean i guess for
his audience do you think this profile
is appropriate though like always what
because we're giving critiques based on
like we're like
yeah yeah i mean for this part yeah it
puts his interests out there and then
he'll bring other girls like other nerd
girls and who's good for him you know
and even the way he's dressing the
photos he's posting and based off of
this prompt and like understanding what
his interests are and like you could
totally picture the girl that he would
be trying to attract and it's like oh
you're doing a good job i think yeah i
feel like okay it's a wholesome little
young relationship
yeah that works for him like if that's
what he's going for this is perfectly
fine yeah yeah okay the next one it says
felt cute might delete that photo no
it's personality it is you know i know
it looks really ugly with this
but to describe the photo he's yeah he's
wearing scuba gear on it's like the
scuba thing mouthpiece is inside his
mouth it's a bathroom selfie and then at
the bottom he captioned it scuba time i
guess if he's that goofy yeah he was a
goofy person but also to me it's just
really butt ugly like he's very handsome
and then you put the scuba gear on and
you look butt ugly but the girls will
have already seen the hair i know
i just don't want to see butt ugly in
the middle of me deciding if we're going
to date or not this would this would
really affect you yeah yeah it would be
like
it affects me positively because i like
the goofiness so like if i already saw
pictures of you normal and then you
being a goofy picture i kind of like it
so like personally this doesn't
this doesn't hit me as like that oh my
god he's so goofy yeah it's more like
okay but that's not our time yeah
thinking about the girls that exactly
like we're talking about from there
personally no but still like i love
goofy guys and i love like oh my god
that's really funny like i love funny
guys just how you do this just looks
like he put it on and he's like oh cool
it's like oh i'm so
yeah scuba things he'll grow up i'm
it's
quirky
sorry jefferson it's a little study we
love you guys
i want you to get your pee pee touch so
we're just helping yeah i do okay i mean
i would like if i had a younger sister i
would let you date her for sure yeah
because i don't think you're going to
touch her
to her that's true
did we just call him a virgin
well she already
said it
maybe not sexually experienced yet
that's what that's what it reads maybe
that's not true
but it is something it reads that way it
is very innocent
which is adorable but it doesn't do
anything for me well i feel like me
trying to look at it through the lens of
the girl that would like him at 1821
this [ __ ] would not do anything for me
out there i think it works a little some
nerdy girl yeah well what else does he
have you know wholesome nerdy girls are
the secret
words
yes girls
i want the
okay last photo here
captioned is this could be us and then
get rid of that one that's stupid is him
on the floor i'm assuming and face down
and someone else took the photo with
their foot barefoot on his back i don't
like that one
i hate that one yeah yeah i hate this
photo nothing going on here it's stupid
it's like a stupid couch a stupid chair
and stupid carpet
carpets
i don't want to see these stupid
actually the carpet kind of looks like
the blanket behind you guys yeah it
should be a blanket
teal carpet with like a saggy peach
couch or something like that
i don't want to see it you could like
that color and not have it as your
carpet yeah i think you're playing a lot
of like i really want to show people how
goofy and silly i am but that's these
aren't the photos that capture them yeah
these are these last two are terrible
you want the first feeling to be oh he's
hot and then the second feeling and kind
of goofy yeah yeah but these two aren't
doing it yeah
i don't like this one even i could i
could pitch you on the the scuba gear
one like i could see them behind you but
this one i can't yeah enough yeah show a
different aspect of your personality in
this at this point because i absolutely
hate that last photo yeah i don't like
it i could i still got your back with
the scuba one
but i kind of want to go through his
instagram photos and pick photos for him
now
we should yeah let's go see if it's
public guys
yeah dang it jefferson come on jeff god
i really want to get rid of that hair
man
well we want to help him and he asked
for critiques and those are some solid
critiques because he can be so hot he's
really happy he is so very attractive
he's very attractive i clicked on the
full face one the up close one and
what's good about this is he's so
attractive and also so innocent that i
feel like he's not a fuckboy yet yeah
that's perfect like whatever girl gets
him as long as she doesn't [ __ ] him over
don't ruin him don't roll jefferson
a lot of guys when it comes to guys a
lot of things that i mean when it comes
to a lot of guys the only things they
really have to change is hair wardrobe
workout that's it yeah yeah and that's
all and amazing the hair makes such a
huge difference and you can be as nerdy
as you want to be yeah but that'll
really help them definitely yes anyway
yes you need a new wardrobe well guess
what we got for you
yes we have stitch fix so your style
isn't one size fits all right no you got
your own style person out there
listening exactly it's about what suits
your body and what suits the moment so
why not shop at a store that is
personalized to your size and style
that's where stitch fix comes in
they have stitch fix freestyle now where
it's a shop that is built just for you
stitch fix freestyle is your trusted
style destination where you can discover
and instantly buy curated items based on
your style likes and lifestyle and you
know how like their regular service is
an actual like curated box for you based
on your style well freestyle you get to
just shop yeah actually curated but you
just love everything in the store yeah
exactly you can just
freestyle it up so with styles for
workouts to work wear for lounging
around the house or for a night out on
the town stitch fix freestyle has
clothes for any occasion plus there's no
subscription required and they offer
free shipping returns and exchanges
whether you're looking for a brand you
love or to try a new one at stitchfix
freestyle you can shop a range of over a
thousand brands personalized to your
size and fit get started today by
filling out your style quiz at
stitchfix.com
mood that's
stitchfix.com mood to try stitch fix
freestyle stitchfix.com
mood
and while you're feeling yourself why
don't you
check out noom and get into a healthy
habit weight loss um this program is
awesome because it's all about your
psychological
uh needs and like it's a psychological
based approach to uh your health journey
and i don't know about you but i've been
on a lot of restricted diets before i've
been on keto i've been on paleo i've
been on like all of all of the ones all
the ones the low carb the low fat the
high whatevers the low sugar but it
always
it always seemed to just be
for a temporary time because i wasn't
fixing the habits that were making me do
bad things yeah your actual behavior
exactly so what noom does is it takes
your goals and um helps you understand
why you're
doing um self sabotaging behavior so for
me personally i was doing a lot of
anxiety eating or stress eating like
when i was stressed out i would just
grab a snack because i thought like i
needed to fill the void somehow and i
didn't even realize i was doing this
until i kept a food journal and realized
like oh i i ate so much more than i
thought i ate because i was just
stressed most of the day and once i
realized that and um and i do that with
social situations too once i realized
that it helps um give you exercises and
tools to counteract those psychological
based
habits um so it's a 10 minute program so
it's 10 minutes a day there's exercises
but there's also just like psychological
things and and basically it's trying to
get your train your brain to develop
good habits healthy habits so that you
don't have to think about calorie
restriction or anything like that you
just are living your life with good
habits
start building better habits for
healthier long-term results sign up for
your trial at noom.com big mood that's
n-o-o-m-dot-com
big mood again to sign up for your trial
go to new dot com slash big mood all
right let's move on to the next video
thanks jefferson
all right you're gonna be a stunner in
five years yeah oh yeah for real yeah
okay so next up we have coconut
coconut
so
that's not a dead president
coconut yeah
no because i heard that's a dead
president it smells like coconut
um why did you think of coconut when you
saw this girl oh
i already had opened that i had the name
locked
yeah
it could have been anyone yeah it could
have been anyone really what if they
actually looked like a coconut oh my
gosh right
well she doesn't look like a guy no she
does not know all right okay so she says
hi big mood i really like the first rate
your profile you did so i definitely
wanted to submit mine and hear your
thoughts right so the first photo we
have here she it's so it's on tinder 19
clothes pharmacy technician at 19. yes
she looks so so young she looks 12. yes
she keeps getting younger she's probably
really pissed that we're saying that too
because she's probably always like no
but i'm oh i'm an adult at this point i
can't tell if you actually look young or
i'm just so old that everybody looks
yeah
oh my god yeah because you know how
really you get to high school and you're
like whoa junior high kids are so yeah
you get to college you're like whoa high
school kids look so young yeah and then
you're an adult and you're like whoa
college kids are so bad kids yeah for
sure and they like now as i'm older i
can see the baby fat in younger people
yeah you can tell and then now i can
tell like older people when does that go
away by the way because it's the 20s
thing right here look at all this oh you
just got it it's going to be like
forever
here she just get fillers there though
all right
so they're just going to get droopy
they're not going to go away yeah it
just gets worse yeah oh cute i picked
you like
doesn't she have a face like that who
from uh from oh yeah and then you called
her coco
[ __ ] the [ __ ] the movie coco uh-huh
the grandmother oh the grails
yeah yeah cocoa from cocoa yeah cocoa
from
anyway so what's coco okay so coconut
here she's 19 pharmacy technician from
new york
new york uh-huh she's
really cute well i mean she went to
school in new york i don't know if she's
from new york that's a good just she
went to a university in new york
actually the initial photo
i'm
oh i love this one yeah the next photo
she looks a bit that's more mature in
this one the first photo that i wish she
would smile more wait for phone it looks
like she's in between it looks like her
mom made her take a picture yeah yeah
like you're not quite smiling and you're
not quite frowning you're just kind of
like okay did you take it yet yeah like
because your makeup looks really pretty
your hair looks really pretty and then
you're like well i think this is good
lighting but i'm not really like there's
not enough personality shining through
yeah because you look so pretty so we
need just a little bit more personality
shining through it's on your you're at
your last hour at the pharmacy and
you're like this customer's asking you
about something that they didn't order
you know what based off of her other
photos i can sense that this initial
first photo is her trying because i i
totally relate to this girl it's her
trying to come off like serious sexy
and that's like that's her that's like
her
her execution of that yeah because i
when i tried taking like serious sexy
poses i look like that exactly
maybe a little bored yeah
you have to practice in the mirror take
a picture
look at it
from like maybe take a few seconds and
then look at it so you're looking at it
with fresh eyes but um yeah i think
it's hard to do the smoldering with your
heart without looking boring unless
you're like someone else or that person
unless you're like gina and you like
look at yourself all the time
you just constantly stare at your face
you know how to like do the subtle
little face changes she studies
yeah she does she studies her face
because she loves herself that's what i
did when i was modeling yeah because
like i had to understand every part of
my body so i studied everything and it's
so subtle right because like this to
what she wants to do is so tiny yeah but
it's just quite not hitting and you know
why i can like seeing this photo too and
it so reminds me of me a lot it's the
attention
i yeah
i always have to go like
like [ __ ] i can't do right now hold on
like you pretend uh
yeah it's like yeah
you're doing it yeah you're doing it
okay yeah
yeah and that's how i could tell i'm
like oh i know exactly what you're
trying to do girl i recognize that face
it's hard taking photos it's so hard
i still can't [ __ ] hate it that's why
i never post on my instagram because the
[ __ ] sucks
let's see something else i want to see
some better pictures next photo here so
she's standing in front of
she looks like she's in a hotel she
doesn't tell it there's like a bowl i
really like the outfit i wish she was
looking more at me and it kind of looks
like because her eyes are half closed
that maybe
she had a few drinks
that's what it reads too it looks like a
mid like candid like sleepy or mid blue
yeah yeah mid blink but i think it's
just showing the dress which is really
pretty the dress is really pretty yeah i
do like the full body shot and see here
she's not trying to be serious yeah but
she nailed it yeah this candid yeah yeah
let's see what else there is okay
here's another why do they look so young
is looks like a middle schooler she
school
there
it
looks like you're in the cafeteria yeah
yeah she's so young so she's biting a
flower and she looks she's not even
looking at the camera she's not looking
at the camera at any of these even the
first photo she's looking at the in the
upper right-hand corner oh yeah you're
like if
she's looking at a viewfinder that's
true yeah so this one we need some eye
contact one girl trying to understand
what she's definitely at school what is
she trying to convey with this photo
yeah maybe if there's a caption or
something like awkward i don't know like
oh look if you're going on hinge you
want to put photos out there that makes
people think hey i want to date her she
seems like you know i think this is
tinder yeah or tinder or whatever these
dating apps are
and this doesn't when i look at it this
photo i'm just i'm not like oh i really
want to go on a date with her oh she's
really oh you know but you know what i
could see her dating jefferson
yeah yeah
right yeah
oh my god yeah yeah the type of girl i'm
picturing when i was picturing who
jefferson
we don't know where she
dreams is new york he's in new jersey
they're really close we're the aunties
now like
how funny okay next photo so she's
sitting on a park bench wearing a mess
can't see your
face don't do the mask photos on dating
apps we don't need that you can put like
i love [ __ ] covet vaccines or
whatever if you want to just show
everyone that you agree with the
campaign
don't cover your face yeah for a dating
profile not for a dating profile
yeah but other than that like you can
actually show you smiling if i could
actually see her face she would be
smiling and it's really cute it's a far
away photo and the face is covered it's
like yeah this is not a this is a no for
me well i mean a positive point is that
at least you see her her whole body yeah
actually she had another one of those
too yeah we're just trying to help her
with the critique part she looks like
she has a nice body if you just alter
little things in each picture yeah it
could work it could work better true
okay next photo
she's squatting okay look at your face
that's an interesting photo
why does she kind of look like me she's
like yeah this one she does i kind of
feel like that's like a candid photo of
me she's doing like a uh
this is the quintessential asian honey
honey flower stand in front of the
flower
like you know you go over to your
auntie's house and can you see me here
oh hold the flower hold the flower like
asian people love standing in front of
flowers for photos but look it looks
like she's like mid lanterns yeah or
something and so her face is like
yeah it's dripping down because it's
like mid-lap or something it's
everything is just kind of just a little
off i don't know i really think it's the
this is like she looked through her
phone she's like i have absolutely no
zero photos of me these are photos other
people took of me i have to put
something about me in a dating profile
the rest of the photos in my phone are
of like her own interests or of other
people or food like i could picture yeah
are they live photos because maybe just
pick a different frame because
this is like very mid something this is
um awkward middle school yeah my mom put
this on her facebook account yeah
what else is there yeah because you're
like mom why'd you put that one yeah
you're smiling at that one my mom's
proud of her garden yeah okay is there
any more photos oh
okay so she captioned the photo with
please use this photo when i become
tick-tock famous
silly
is that a filter with the glasses or are
those those
so she's being very self-deprecating and
funny she's like i know i'm not the
like i'm not being the hot girl at least
i think she actually is really pretty
but she's like kind of making herself
ugly on purpose or something and not
it's not that she is ugly but it's like
why is she trying so hard to not be like
the pretty one when she really could be
she's got a little self-esteem i could
tell i could tell also low self-esteem
from the poses of her photos from the
photos that she's picking also from the
like
especially this particular photo with
the pigtails it's like look i'm trying
to be i'm trying to show you a different
side of my personality but i'm not super
confident about it but i'm still going
to try to like show it to you
i don't know i this makes me feel like
um like you are not everyone should be
the main character of their own story
but you're letting yourself your own
story you're the oh that's your best
friend
yeah you're the funny neighbor best
friend instead of being like well i mean
i guess not every person like wants the
pressure of being the
god girl or the main character type so
like i don't know like even like
jefferson right like he doesn't seem
like he's that concerned with being
visually
the hottest guy on the block or whatever
he's just like i care more about like
my hobbies than i do about being like
the hot person it's just difficult when
you're in a dating app because
everything is so superficial
so
but also maybe that works because you're
only going to attract someone who's just
as like i don't care about being the
main character yeah i really want these
two to come across each other's posts
all right next photo so she's with a
friend she's wearing a baseball cap
um yeah it's just kind of like oh i
found this photo
it's young and sweet she's really pretty
like i feel like she is
she could have a major [ __ ] glow up
like she gets a little bit older maybe
like 25
she could make she has great bone
structure great skin this is just really
hard because they're teenagers
i'm like oh she could glow up so hard
yeah her eyebrows are great too i love
those browns oh those are the brows that
we kill for mm-hmm
i could have had her at like the 20 or
50 uh i can't make it you could have
you're trying to say how old you are
i could be her mom yeah
oh that's what you're saying yeah yeah
it just feels like i'm raiding a child
like a kid's profile it's very hard for
me romantic yeah please it's very
strange because they are so young
because it makes me want to go like oh
you'd look so cute if you just
straightened your hair right here like
how jess was in that last in the last
one where i'm like oh just take the hat
off for this photo yeah yeah
like do your hair this way but yeah is
there any paragraphs or um no she just
said photos she's just almost like it's
the last photo her at a party wearing
sunglasses well that one's kind of funny
having fun
i think the outfit makes her look really
like really young yeah like 12. she's
very conservative in her clothing yeah
she probably is very conservative family
was that the only one that dressed like
a [ __ ] at 19. no no no you weren't
no you were not was that just our
generation or then again i already was
going dancing at 19. true
yeah so this is 22 different i feel like
she definitely has very strict parents
you could tell her and you know what
that actually adds to the back story if
she is really self-conscious because
usually strict parents don't allow kids
to have social skills like to actually
go with like their friend's house and
actually get to know people and like
practice those social skills so then it
makes sense why she's really awkward in
her photos and like why it's like kind
of difficult for her to put herself out
there because it's like [ __ ] like i
never really was allowed to yeah she
hasn't come into her own yet yeah that's
the recipe for a crazy whole face later
yeah
and we don't want you to do the crazy
whole face want you to like kind of just
slowly can if you want
if you want to you can but that can also
be a little nuts but as you're innocent
go with jefferson yeah
to me i also just in a general life
sense i feel like
i can see a little bit of myself in her
and that she's gonna because she's
probably really [ __ ] smart and she's
a pharmacy tech already and i feel like
she's gonna do the thing where like she
just tries so hard at work but doesn't
focus much on interpersonal
relationships maybe this is all judgment
obviously i have no clue but i feel like
you also need to make sure that you're
getting really good at networking people
skills all that kind of stuff that's
going to make your career go further
than just hunkering down and doing the
math yeah like you're gonna really
really need to like i want you to make
sure that you focus on that's part of it
yeah it's like still part of the career
yeah because if you're just like you
need to diffuse that part if you just
hunker down and do the math like you're
gonna get passed over for promotions
like all this stuff and i feel like
you're gonna work yourself to the bone
you need to make sure that you like find
a way to get that self-esteem up
yes and out
yeah definitely taking a whole dancing
class really boosted like that she's
probably like exactly
no it's like it's because it's like
athletic it's all women in there
and like i was because i was super goofy
like i would like giggle during sex like
i was super
nerdy and
not
very openly sexual and i took a paul
dancing class i've talked about this a
billion times but like to
open up because i was getting sent out
for these like sexy roles and it was
just not matching like i was very i was
too goofy and taking that class not only
made me more like
sexually liberated but more confident
like in who i am
as a woman
and like
the whole picture
and i remember that being like a turning
point but even just it was fun too like
you're
kind of just opening up and i've been
wanting to take one day hanging on like
a pull up remind me of jungle juice it's
hard you gotta have good upper body
strength skin burns and [ __ ] you get
bruised up and it's not easy
it's rough but it does i i took one a
little bit too in austin and it was nice
you do a long time ago oh you can get
thigh high boots though that prevent the
bruising oh nice
so
with the last part with jefferson we
actually forgot to
swipe right or left oh
someone had suggested in the comments
and i don't know if you guys are are
open to this but they're like instead of
swipe left or right because it seems to
be personal preference right what about
just saying the type of person that
would swipe who would swipe
career driven career driven yeah and
then they can explore their bodies
together it's so cute yeah and i don't
think she would ruin our jefferson no
she wouldn't [ __ ] him over she can't
ruin him
or jefferson and her they must be
protected they wouldn't ruin each other
coconut and jefferson yes
and coconut trees i love them all right
next profile we have here who is this
gina washington
washington so now we are going back to
the presidency for the boys
i do not know like it's not explicitly
stated anywhere whether he's straight
or not
let's just assume i guess i don't know
it's easier to assume i'm sure that we
yeah he's uh straight okay so he writes
hey ladies love the show if you ever
rate dating profiles again maybe you
could look mine over i've been single
for a while and only just started using
dating apps so maybe y'all could help me
out yay yeah so here is washington look
at that first photo here he looks
british i don't know if it's how he's
standing i thought he was british yeah
i love him he's just white i think he's
just no like we stand a certain way and
there's a yeah an essence okay yes i
agree because starting off with a great
outfit and he's wearing smiling already
and it's just like a natural looking
style i definitely want to go to the bar
with this one right yeah yeah yeah it
looks like the pub this is the puppy the
pup
the
he captioned it guess the back story of
this photo he's standing there with the
suit it looks like in a parking lot it
does look like church there's like an
old man and a little kid little girl in
the background
and yeah who wears a hat like that
british people in the
background it's an american handicapped
parking style yeah
come on guys come on they stole it from
america not all the way people are
british
that's funny no but also british people
have like like some british people like
there's british actors yeah that have
like this look like this really quick
what's that british actors
and and then he was with the he was like
he played a brother
of this other sister and they both look
similar and it's like the british girl
like she's like a comedian oh a zombie
rebel
yeah rebel wilson is the sister of this
guy that i'm trying to talk about oh my
god i thought you would know casey come
on never mind okay are you thinking of
the guy in that zombie movie the funny
one the shot the
oh yeah yeah but there's this other
actor i have in mind that's a british
actor and he look like
washington looks a lot like him to me
yeah let's move on okay i could see him
being rebel wilson's brother yeah
okay so now it says he's a 33 year old
man he's 5 10.
um
he
where's greenfield
green
charlemont i know i was like is that
european that sounds european exactly oh
no i don't know
type in the other one massachusetts okay
so it's in europe
okay
okay so um
he's going to be like i'm not british i
was born in the uk came over on the
mayflower
so it he has a
blue collar job it looks like possibly
yeah i'm not sure maybe i mean well
that's just the company he works at but
we don't know we don't know what he does
we don't know what he does there
he's and he says politically moderate
which that's cool that's cool so let's
see what what else 510 33
years old right okay next one it's the
prompt says this year i really want to
start traveling again
okay why is there a girl in this photo
and then i make a photo under there it's
captioned me in the wild and then it's
like them at a lake you need to specify
that you're supposed to say or something
because if not getting the [ __ ] out of
here okay so tiffany was saying it's a
picture of him and a girl they're in
like these the girl is behind him in an
inner tube on a lake somewhere and he's
in the form yeah but we're mostly seeing
the girl and yeah
no [ __ ] that girl unless she's your
sister but why is she the yeah she's the
main focus true don't triangulate me
with another [ __ ] yeah because there's
the only travel picture he had yeah he's
trying to show like see i can go on
adventures i'm in a kayak yeah um
crop her out
but then it's just his face just push up
her out of the tube it's like he's just
with a tube or just or just put this is
my sister that's all yeah that would be
a lot more helpful instead of me in the
wild it could have been me in the wild
with my sister yeah well those prompts
are all pre-done so if you click on it
if you click on the photo it gives you a
chance to add a caption so like maybe if
you were in the app and you clicked on
it and said this is my sister i'd be
like oh okay and i would keep going
true next photo it says are you a dog
person because and then it's a photo of
him getting licked in the face there's
two doggies in this oh yeah there's a
dog back there also like i mean i
haven't seen enough close-up of his face
yet so all of these are still yeah he's
very squinty it's true or sunglasses
half face i love this and the dog is the
main focus of the yeah like in all these
photos
don't make other things the focus of the
photo so much true but i do like it i do
like it it's a cute photo yeah
that's cute i do like your dog
all right next one it's uh the prompt
says what i order for the table he says
fries you can never have enough and then
the next one says biggest risk i've ever
taken and it's a photo of him it looks
like a at a podium
like public speaking or something
about ski pics i don't understand what
this is
those are like those are like the
photocopy right of like he just pulled
it off the website
and a photographer takes the photos but
you need to pay for them otherwise you
could just see the previews on the
website he just pulled the preview on
the website it's watermarked across his
face
what is this photo though like what i
think you're supposed to be asking
or maybe if you click on it you see the
caption maybe he's singing it kind of
looks like he's sort of singing well the
prompts the prompts with the photo it's
like supposed to get you to say so what
are you doing in this like what was that
risky thing you did publicly
yeah public speaking is america's number
one fear yeah
actually i think i want to say he's
singing it looks more like he's singing
who sings at a podium i don't know like
like because he's like his eyes are
closed and squinting and his mouth is
open like it looks more like a singing
thing
it could be let's see is there any
paragraphs of like
okay another one the prompt says i get
along best with people who and he writes
speak their mind even if they think
they'll end up sounding foolish i would
always prefer to know what you're
thinking that's good yeah it says
foolish british people oh my god
i agree with that and yeah i don't see
him spell color
[Music]
yeah i like this yeah i like that too
yeah honesty he values honesty not
process behind it
and he's informative he doesn't put
something he's like likes movies
you know
that gets me to think like oh you care
about being honest in real relation like
friendships and relationships yeah okay
next one it's the prompt says my dog
looks at me like this and it's a photo
of his dog very cute but it's taking up
space that is not yeah i don't need this
we already did it we don't need this
precious real estate in your profile
yeah yeah it's a great photo though but
that's for instagram not for our dating
profile true
i agree last photo here is caption life
outtake and then it's him it's a up
close photo of him
in a snowy background and see this
should be the main picture because they
get a full view of what you look like
without glasses on without like
sunglasses on right i love the first
photo though i don't think so because
this one looks like there's a filter on
it because his eyebrows have disappeared
that's it i i kind of don't like this
one i think he looks more handsome in
the first one and i i kind of don't like
this one because it looks filtered and
his face is washed out oh he doesn't
have gloves or maybe he doesn't have
eyebrows period so people have light
eyebrows okay
actually between the two i do like this
one better yeah the church one is better
but it does look like he doesn't have
eyebrows and this one looks washed out
the lighting is not good on it so i
would take a different one i really like
this photo though because this is the
only photo you actually see his eyes and
his eye color so pretty he does have
really pretty blue eyes i think he just
needs to retake it i like this photo
because it's you can see his face very
clear his eyes are beautiful i just wish
he was smiling bigger like his first
photo yeah yeah this one doesn't hurt
this is like all a lot of guys do that
they do they're like the unsure sounds
like they're trying to figure out how to
take yeah like is the phone working
right that's yeah the mid thought all
right now i want to talk about my most
favorite sheets in the entire world
attitude oh my gosh
they're they are literally made into a
heaven changer it's the best
but
your actual sheets though the dirty
little not so secret about bedding
is that it while cotton might be the
most popular fabric
for sheets duvets and pillowcases it's
also the most damaging to our planet did
you know that stop damaging earth
that's why i'm so thrilled to introduce
you
etitude which offers sustainably made
bedding sleepwear bathware and
accessories all made from 100
organic bamboo fabric so soft it's the
softest oh my gosh material i've ever
tried it even so my sheets actually came
in in their own little bag yeah and i
use that bag to put my pillow that i
take on like whenever i i travel on an
airplane so i put it in there so i'm
always like feeling my edit to sheet
with my oh that's smart
and i love it because it keeps it's like
also really cool too like
yeah cooling up
and it's so like it breathes so well
it's so soft it's so comfortable because
you're in a cloud i'm such a huge fan
so
unlike cotton which consumes massive
amounts of water energy and chemicals
during production etitude uses organic
bamboo the most resource efficient plant
on the planet etitude's 100 organic
bamboo fabric has a unique silky smooth
and feathery soft texture that is
similar to silk it delivers unparalleled
comfort that actually feels better than
cotton i can attest to this nikki can
attest to this oh my god it's amazing so
if you struggle with being really hot
with your current sheets solve that
problem with attitude right now you can
get twenty percent off your order plus
free shipping when you visit attitude
dot com slash mood and enter promo code
mood remember that's attitude as an eco
attitude order today for free shipping
and 20 off your order at etitude.com
mood promo code mood so you guys know
how obsessed i am with bidets
and if you don't have one i think lesser
review
because shout out to japan true um but
our sponsor is hello tushy
hella tissue is the modern bidet for
people who poop just poop wash and pat
dry it washes your butt for a better
clean than toilet paper the hello tissue
bidet washes your butt with water for a
better clean and also water is less
irritating and more soothing for your
butthole i like how they put b hole
it's also easy to install attach it to
your toilet in under 10 minutes no
electricity or plumbing is needed
and when you use a hello tishi
it reduces your toilet paper used by 80
saving you money uh in the long run see
that was always the thing the reason for
not getting a bidet was i didn't have an
outlet next to the toilet but this one
you don't need it it uses the the
toilets water
thing water pressure thingy i don't know
what's going on it's
it's also very eco-friendly and stylish
and they have a full product line to
make the restroom the best room
including a hello tissue ottoman it's
the sleekest toilet stool designed to
help you poop at 100 100 of the time
they also have a hello tushy brush it's
the only toilet brush with disposable
scrubbing pads so you can use a clean
brush every time
so start washing your butt butt with
hello tissue bidet for a better clean go
to hellotissue.com big mood to get 10
off plus free shipping
this is a special offer for our
listeners it's at hellotissue.com
big mood for 10 off and after you buy
and install your health tissue show it
off tag us at hellotushy on instagram no
more dirty butts no dirty butts
all right so back to washington here
this is uh this is his profile what do
you what do you guys thought
you know what just struck me about that
last photo
his eyes remind me of tom hardy's eyes
his eyeballs remind me of tom hardy's
eyeball so now i get the british thing
that you guys are talking about
also his lips yep his oh yeah he got
those big old lips okay so i do love his
lips and i do love his eyes i just think
in this photo it feels like because of
the time of day or it's just so white
out there because of the snow or it's a
filter something's washing him out a
little bit too much i wish you could
hear people's voices on these people you
guys just want to know if he's british
yeah
you just want to hear if he has an
accent no you know what i do really fall
in love with people's voices yeah like
they're the way they carry the way they
speak often reflects how they carry
themselves and i think it makes a huge
difference too yeah it was just like
good day mate or something that you
would love that no we had a high pitched
voice it's like different than like hey
you want to go to bed or like you that's
like that's true even [ __ ] even in the
you're so right like in the wait is it
cadence yeah
since the the
like how grounded they are right and
like they're self-confident yeah i wish
they just had a voice sample
well actually i think on hinge you can
upload a very short video like 10
seconds or less i just want a voice
sample yeah so maybe you could try
taking a i don't know a candid video
kind of isn't there a dating app that
was like voice only i remember hearing
about that i think there is i really do
fall in love with people's voices i i
when i look at um
washington here he looks like someone
that um probably is like the sweetest
person yeah yeah like he makes a good
husband
you know don't break your heart you know
he'll take care of you yeah i like his
eyes something about looking directly
into his eyes i trust him
yeah have a fan of this photo even
though you don't like it because it
washes you out i'm a really big fan of
this photo in front of the snow i do too
i love this one what he doesn't have are
those creepy shark eyes that some guys
have yeah like you know he's going to
wreck your life yeah like he
has boy eyes
oh [ __ ] you know what i just realized we
keep talking about his eyes but the fans
can't even see them i know
nice blue i really want you guys to
realize that because atlantic those are
his best feature are his eyes yeah like
i could actually look into it
like a mask
like a zorro
just like erase the black around the
eyeballs
cover everything but the eyeballs that's
it because this one we're talking about
the most
why don't everything else put the
eyeballs i brought eyeballs and the lips
because
that's funny i love you yeah yeah so
what kind of woman would be i wish i
said what he did for work oh yeah it
does we're just both yeah
it works out we know where but we don't
know what kind of woman he would be with
because he looks like such a sweet sweet
pea he needs himself a fierce
like woman that will stand up for yeah
the mama bear he needs some mama bear
because he's so sweet and kind and quiet
that you know some people kind of might
like
be mean to him he's a little bit of a
pushover because he's so sweet i think
teddy bears he looks like a guy that's
down for whatever she wants to do like
so i wonder if it's an adventurous girl
yeah like just someone that's like gonna
be the one the instigator of like yeah
hey i want to go here and then he's like
all right yeah and because he says he
wants to travel more and i i feel like
he needs that like instigator girl
yeah that was me and our our marriage
yeah i could totally see that
yeah that's so true yeah he's a fire
sign girl i searched up his company and
i still don't know what they do
yeah it's a it's um
manufacturing yeah it's in manufacturing
but we don't know what he does there
either way i think it's a good job like
i would be like okay cool that sounds
like a good job
um and he went to college and everything
that's all good but obviously we need
some better photos but like it's you
probably gotta get one of your boys to
like help you take some more like
because like the one at church that's a
great photo like we need you to be
naturally
smiling and doing stuff and maybe not
have a girl there unless it's quite
clear that it's a sister or a cousin or
something but yeah so some of them are
kind of wasted like i think the dog when
the dog one is just just alone the dog
one's kind of a waste of a photo we
already saw in the other photo and then
the one of you public speaking or
singing or something it's
it's not really interesting it's not
flattering either
and then it's just like flying over your
face right really see yeah
yeah so i think you i mean you're
probably not gonna have a good time on
the dating app because people are very
judgmental and very superficial and
these are these are just like throwaway
photos like it's it's again it's
someone's camera roll that doesn't ever
take pictures of themselves which i
understand yeah a lot of guys don't like
taking pictures of you you treat this
like a resume
yeah show arrange show like your
interests
yeah you're gonna have to get one of
your boys to help you take a few more
photos alright guys so now for our last
profile here we have a girl what's her
name yeah what's her name gina
venus
um yeah yeah like venus so she says
hello big mood girls just finish
watching the first rating your dating
profiles i absolutely love the concept i
hope y'all can take the time to review
mines too just curious what y'all would
say and so first photo here it's a photo
of her it's her full body photo which i
fully appreciate
um i like this and like
like immediately i get your vibe yeah i
know who you are yeah
even the setting the surroundings
like everything about this picture i'm
like i get your vibe it's like indie
chick like
coffee shop yeah
likes concerts yes yeah for sure okay so
she's 29 years old
she went to school in texas
and says no hookups please just friends
yeah so the paragraph says no hookups
please just friends and good vibes i
genuinely want to get to know people and
go on adventures i choose peace over
everything else and her anthem is sugar
honey iced tea by princess nokia so this
isn't for a romantic prince i guess so
this is like one of those friend ones
yeah yeah i mean like she's putting out
there exactly what she wants and i like
that about her yeah let's see some more
photos the first one is pretty good
start
yeah oh she's got see there's videos ooh
it's screaming it's screencasting
yeah so i can't play the video but there
is a video here and it looks like she's
like bedroom i approve of using videos
god i appreciate her profile so much
because it tells me so much yeah it's a
full story this is what you want on your
profile like tell your full story
so we can like
assess it properly when we're trying to
decide if we want to go on a date with
you right next photo it's a close-up of
her really cute selfie that's filtered
love it
yes not too heavily filtered you can
tell yeah second or the next photo after
that is this is a little bit more
filtered look at that clear
faces though like up front face yeah you
see her whole face yeah i'm not going to
be shocked when i
go meet you yes
she's also really pretty by the way very
gorgeous yeah look at her hair
ooh i love that
she's so cute she looks funny
free-spirited she's sitting on like some
graffitied up uh what is it steps i
think like
and then you could see some of the city
in the background yeah her she has her
legs crossed like her arms crossed super
like flirty kind of photo her
environments reflect her personality
yeah yeah i really like it
yeah and you could tell her personality
also from her outfits that she's picking
yeah exactly yeah i love it i would wear
her clothes i love her clothes yeah yeah
they're so cute the next photo she's
sitting on a couch with her legs crossed
there's like some artwork behind her i
want to hang out with this girl yeah she
seems really cool
i like her i don't know i i don't know
what it is about these photos that are
better i can't say why but they just
kind of sorry i could tell you okay for
my opinion
she's confident
she's exuding like i know who i am yeah
if you want to come get to know me then
that's cool i mean look at the first
photo she was posing she was public
posing and it's like a full body face
and everything like this girl just
screams confidence yeah and that makes
me want to meet her and hang out there
yeah but the thing about her her face is
also she exudes confidence in her body
language and in her photos but her face
also says she's very friendly yeah
it's like not just confidence that like
outward like i'm confident about me it's
like a grounded like
i know yeah i know who i am yeah i'm
just here for a good time like i believe
her when she says yeah i'm here for good
vibes yeah just to get to know people
yeah i agree because even in this photo
where she's crossing her legs like she
has a serious face she's not even
smiling or anything but it's warm it
looks inviting there's a glimmer behind
the blank face there's still a glimmer
behind it that some people can't figure
out yet maybe because they don't feel
very confident right like you said yeah
yeah open you can really see it in
photos it really really translates in
photos
i feel like any any guy that would look
at this would be like oh you know or for
me personally i feel like if i hung out
with her i'd have a great time
definitely next book she
okay so next photo she's sitting at a
table
and she has like her hand like gently
what is it like how do i describe her
caressing her chest there's like the
sunlight behind her she's a very
familiar photo she's wearing a flowery
dress with like a flower crown she can
also see her different like hairstyles
that she's had really fun she's a very
feminine woman with like florals all
over the place and her hair makeup
always done but she also has like badass
boots and so yeah she's very balanced
yeah yeah
she's in touch with her feminine side
and her masculine side she takes good
care of herself
i love it okay again like she's just
killing it with the environment like
yeah everything about each one of her
pictures speaks to who she is they're
purposeful photos like this photo is
kind of saying something like they're
not just like oh these are accidentally
on my phone like yeah like she took
these pictures on purpose and and it
shows her personality and that's what
everyone needs to try to do yes so this
photo here she's standing very
confidently with like her arm behind her
head in front of a graffiti
wall and she has like a plaid shirt tied
around her waist
it's like arms are open not crossed over
her like she's hiding she's very
confident legs are like you know spread
not spread but you know like standing at
a very strong stance yeah strong stance
yeah strong and open stance yeah yeah i
really like this photo a lot like her
face looks so pretty yeah every photo is
posted with intention mm-hmm and this is
her last photo even like the coloring
yeah the photos yeah like i like the
saturation saturation
this last photo here she's standing in
front of an atm and like more graffiti
uh stuff with like a fence and she's
like uh showing off she went wigs yeah
she's like she's totally showing off
legs it's but it's like
tasteful yeah it's not it's balanced
everything about her is balanced yeah
sweater
i like you she's mexican we like you
venus i like you a lot yes
i would totally swipe
right yeah it says she went to a
community college in central texas so i
might even [ __ ] be able to meet this
chicken
yeah and also like we can't say her name
but her name is so beautiful it is
unique i [ __ ] it goes with her
personality it does yeah i love it oh my
god girl you're killing it she's cool
i like her good job i don't think i've
ever really no critiques
or anything really yeah
okay well one thing i would say is she
says she wants to go on adventures i
would like to know what your idea of
that is okay that's the only one thing
like i can kind of get like maybe coffee
shop um echo park type of vibes but
i just don't know like what's your idea
well do you think that that's the
starter point to where and now you have
the conversation like you swipe on her
because you like her vibe and then now
you say well what kind of adventures do
you want yeah true that's true this is
how dating profiles should be done clear
photos and a bunch of them she gave us a
lot of video good photos and a video
good confidence
showing you her entire pro uh
personality in her profile she's 29 you
know girls just like hit their peak when
they're about to be 30. yeah everyone
says uh you hit a wall but we actually
hit a peak you know self-confidence is
there i love it that's so true that's
what happened to me over when i turned
32 yeah they're totally tiffany's
happened 30's are better for us even
though guys are like ooh no one wants to
thank you because you're 30 now but it's
like we feel better about ourselves you
know why though because they're like
great we can't take advantage of it
exactly now you actually know what you
want right
you actually stand up for yourself yeah
what a bitter old woman i mean we're
also talking about society who's who
like
women were married off at [ __ ] 12.
yeah so 30 seems so far and old to them
their peaks should be submissive yeah
waves yeah yeah
moldable
yeah
all right well
thank you guys for watching uh this
dating profile review
send us your profiles so we can keep
doing these episodes if you guys like
this yeah let's go and if you're
interested in any of our people you let
us know we'll maybe hook it up yeah yeah
you're both fans of the shows
so you submit your profile and tell us
who you're interested in and we'll send
it to them and then we'll send it to
them and be like are you down you're all
handling this rare that's a lot of work
yeah
[Applause]
i mean all it is it's passing a message
i'm just being a messenger passing the
note in class yeah jefferson and coco
not let's see if you guys want to hang
out too yeah and i want to hang out with
you i do yeah
like when we go over to visit yeah jess
we all gotta have lunch yeah
all right guys thank you for watching
make sure to check out our sponsors if
you would like to support the show
that's the best way to support the show
also give us five stars on itunes uh
thumbs this video up and comment down
below what you liked most about this
video we love you bye